the World Cup is kicking off right now
in Brazil a place that eats sleeps and
breathes football so why have so many in
the country turn their back on the cup
it's because no matter who wins the cost
of hosting this international event may
make resilience with biggest losers of
all I'm Francesca and here fourways
Brazil is already losing the world cup
to make room for new stadiums and
related projects reveal has evicted tens
of thousands of people from favelas poor
neighborhoods around many of the host
cities relocated residents have
complained that housing compensations in
the government was either too low or
non-existent often homes were simply
marked with a number before the
bulldozers came canopy sis Becky was
eighty percent Deborah door miss abuse
weatherman's policy myself up to a card
sheet Abu Sayyaf war z come about in the
run-up to the cup the government tried
to take control of the favelas from the
gangs that have traditionally ruled them
it sent in what it called pacifying
police units to try to stop crime but
some say the specification was really
just excessive aggression that is
unjustly targeted residents Brazil is
spending more than any country ever has
on the World Cup eleven and a half
billion dollars it's a price tag that
has many resilience furious sixteen
percent of the population lives below
the poverty line an investment is badly
needed in schools and hospitals so many
have been wondering where the billions
for new stadiums came from last summer
more than a million took to the streets
around the country in what started out
as a protest against a bus fare increase
but quickly became about government
spending corruption and the World Cup
demonstrations lasted for weeks until
finally the hikes were rolled back but
this year protests continued May
fifteenth marked a national day of
action against the world cup protesters
in 12 host cities marched blockaded and
face down police to voice their
frustration and even though you'd think
hundreds of thousands of tourists
descending on Brazil would be good for
the economy the influx has meant prices
for things like a simple sandwich have
skyrocketed residents of reals
gennaro were so tired of being ripped
off they started a Facebook page to
encourage boycotting overpriced
businesses their symbol a surreal rail
so with all these massive investments
being made out of the taxpayers pocket
Brazilians at least have the profits
from the world cup to look forward to
right well not quite these venit
sponsors and suppliers profit from the
world cup tax-free all are exempt from
income import and industrial taxes for
up to four years after the event
brazilian football legend Romario now a
member of parliament summed it up
fujioka for gastro market america asia q
haces quedas a beer what they do say
construido safety cincuenta muqadas
popular Jeff fifa sharokina page mont
Onstad them to northeast odd yes I you
and those were four ways Brazil is
already losing the world cup who are you
rooting for